Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P. Many of you might have
heard about Trump derangement syndrome. Well,
a caller called in who believes that there is
Biden derangement syndrome going on down in
Texas where he lives. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hi, David. This is Chris down in
Texas. And I notice in my town I see f Biden
bumper stickers. F Biden stickers on the gas. Oh,
yeah. Signs and yards. And it seems like there's a
lot of Biden derangement syndrome down.
Speaker 1: Here, I would say.
Speaker 4: So it really gets talked about. And
then thinking about Barack Obama, how they were
so obsessed with what he wore and the birtherism,
seems like there's been a lot of derangement
syndrome. On their side for quite a long time.
Speaker 1: Of course there has. And they just
love to say, oh, Trump derangement syndrome.
You know, I was not not long ago I was in
well, I guess I don't know if it's considered
upstate New York or not. I know that, you know,
in the city, what's considered upstate is
different. But in the Hudson Valley area and
Hudson, New York itself is quite liberal. And
it's become kind of like a, you know, a place
where people from the city drive up and hang out
for the weekend, great restaurants and, you know,
furniture shops and all of it. But in the small
towns surrounding Hudson, as we were driving in,
there were a shocking number of places selling
Biden paraphernalia, anti Biden, I should say,
you know, f j b let's go, Brandon. Weird. Like
voodoo type dolls of Joe Biden and stuff like
that. So if that's going on in New York State and
I know that the further you get from the city,
the more right wing New York, New York State gets.
But I can only imagine what's going on in Texas.
And yes, there is quite a bit of derangement on
today's bonus show. We are going to talk about the
new UK Prime Minister, Liz Truss. It's happening,
it has happened and what happens now with the
relationship with the United States? A New Mexico
official has been ousted for participating in the
January 6th insurrection. That's good news. We'll
tell you the details. And Senator Ted Cruz, one of
the most disgusting members of the U.S. Senate,
wants to block student loan forgiveness. What's
the argument? Well, we'll tell you on the bonus
show, all of those stories and more when producer
Pat joins me on the bonus show. You can sign up
today, join Pacman dot com. If you're waiting for
that sweet, sweet discount for a membership, get
on my newsletter. Because on September 19th, nine,
19, we are doing a 19 themed membership special.
It's going to be nuts. Our lawyer. Accountant and
entire staff is begging me with tears in their
eyes. David Sir, don't do this discount, but I
am committed to doing it. And you can be notified
on September 19th of this great opportunity to
become a member simply by getting on my newsletter
at David Pakman dot com. I'll see you on the bonus
show today if you are already a member. Otherwise,
we'll be back tomorrow with a brand new video.